After getting everybody's hopes raised over
the weekend with the release of a surprise
teaser, the truth behind the Danny McBride-starring
Crocodile Dundee reboot has been discovered...and
it's all a lie.
An investigation conducted by the Brisbane
Times has uncovered that the movie is nothing
more than a viral marketing stunt for Tourism
Australia.
The "movie" was initially announced on Friday
in an exclusive report by People, which featured
deceptive quotes from McBride and Paul Hogan,
the original movies' Mick Dundee.
"That's not a knife.
That's a knife."
Hogan said in the People reveal,
"Throughout the past few years, I've been
thinking about how to bring Dundee to a new
generation.
I'm excited to introduce the new Crocodile
Dundee to the world and look forward to sharing
more news about those involved very soon."
Hogan previously served as a Australia tourism
pitchman in 1984 with the "G'Day Mate" campaign,
which continues to inform just about every
stereotypical view Americans hold of the land
down under.
"Come and say good day and I'll slip an extra
shrimp on the barbie for ya."
The initial Dundee trailer was met with skepticism
from the start by many commentators in the
entertainment industry, who questioned how
a movie with an IMDB-estimated budget of $30
million and the involvement of such busy performers
as McBride and Chris Hemsworth could've been
made in absolute secrecy.
While Hemsworth's involvement in the movie's
second teaser appeared to add some credibility
to the project, others noticed the curious
fact that Hemsworth is currently employed
as a Tourism Australia ambassador.
That was enough to convince many that the
movie wasn't quite on the level.
Thanks to the Brisbane Times, that theory
has now been all-but-proven.
Alas, poor Dundee—we hardly knew ye.
Everybody pour out a little Bundaberg for
the summer we could've had.
"G'day, losers."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!